REST OF THE MEDIA NEEDS TO
CATCH UP.
MONOLOGUE.
♪ A MAJOR DEVELOPMENT IN THE
CLINTON SERVER SCANDAL.
YOU'VE GOT TO PAY CLOSE
ATTENTION TONIGHT.
THIS IS GOING TO BE A
BLOCKBUSTER HOUR.
WE HERE AT FOX NEWS HAVE
OBTAINED THE DRAFT OF JAMES
COMEY'S EXONERATION
STATEMENT THAT LET HILLARY
CLINTON OFF THE HOOK AS IT
RELATES TO THE EMAIL SERVER.
THE DOCUMENT SHOWS THAT THE
TERM GROSSLY NEGLIGENT WAS,
IN FACT, CHANGED TO EXTREME
CARELESSNESS IN TWO PLACES.
REMEMBER, GROSSLY NEGLIGENT
CLINTON BROKE THE LAW.
AND HERE'S THE OTHER PIECE
OF NEW INFORMATION.
IN THE PART WHERE COMEY WAS
TALKING ABOUT FOREIGN
ACTORS, ACCESSING CLINTON
SERVER, THE WORD LIKELY
ACCESSED WAS REMOVED.
THIS IS NATIONAL SECURITY.
ALL OF THIS CONTINUES TO
PROVE THAT THE FIX WAS IN
FROM THE VERY BEGINNING OF
WHAT IS A FARCE OF AN
BEFORE THE INVESTIGATION WAS
ANYWHERE NEAR CONCLUDED.
AND HERE'S WHY.
THE DRAFT STATEMENT IS FROM
MAY 2ND, 2016.
HILLARY AND OTHERS IN HER
CASE WASN'T INTERVIEWED BY
THE FBI UNTIL THE FOURTH OF
JULY WEEKEND.
HOW COULD COMEY, HOW COULD
THIS HILLARY LOVING, TRUMP
HATING FBI AGENT PETER
STRZOK REACH ANY CONCLUSION
ABOUT CLINTON SERVER
INVESTIGATION TWO MONTHS
BEFORE THEY EVEN INTERVIEWED
HER OR OTHER KEY PEOPLE?
THE FIX WAS IN.
PLAIN AND SIMPLE.
WE NOW HAVE THE EVIDENCE.
AND FOX NEWS LEGAL AM LIST
GREGG JARRETT SAYS WHAT WE
JUST LAID OUT COULD MEAN
JAMES COMEY IS GUILTY OF
OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE.
THAT IS A CRIME.
THAT IS A FELONY.
WE'LL HEAR FROM HIM COMING
UP LATER IN THE PROGRAM.
ALSO TONIGHT, JUDICIAL WATCH
HAS UNCOVERED ABSOLUTELY
BOMBSHELL REPORT ABOUT THE
SPECIAL TREATMENT THAT
HILLARY CLINTON AND HER TOP
AIDE HUMA ABEDIN WERE GIVEN
BY THE OBAMA STATE
DEPARTMENT.
WE NOW HAVE DOCUMENTS THAT
WERE OBTAINED THROUGH THE
FREEDOM OF INFORMATION ACT
IT SHOWS THAT CLINTON AND
HER TOP AIDE, THEY WERE
GIVEN PERMISSION BY THE
STATE DEPARTMENT TO REMOVE
BOTH ELECTRONIC AND PHYSICAL
RECORDS THAT THEY CLAIM
WERE, QUOTE, PERSONAL AND,
QUOTE, UNCLASSIFIED AND
NON-RECORDED MATERIALS.
ACCORDING TO JUDICIAL
RELEASE, THIS INCLUDES
RECORDS OF HILLARY CLINTON'S
CALLS, HER SCHEDULES, WHICH
CONVENIENTLY WILL NOT BE
MADE AVAILABLE TO YOU, THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
PHYSICAL FILES FROM THE
QUOTE:  MUSLIM ENGAGEMENT
DOCUMENTS.
THIS IS BEYOND OUTRAGEOUS.
AND IT SHOWS THAT THERE IS A
DIFFERENT SET OF RULES AND
STANDARDS FOR THE CLINTONS
AND THEIR ALLIES.
JUSTICE SYSTEM.
WE HAVE BEEN TALKING ABOUT
AND WARNING YOU ABOUT.
MAKE NO MISTAKE, SHOULDN'T
BE SURPRISED BECAUSE IT'S
ALL PART OF A PATTERN WHEN
THE FIX IS IN AGAINST
BERNIE.
THE FIX IS IN HERE.
THE FIX IS ON OTHER ISSUES,
REMOVING, DESTROYING
DOCUMENTS.
THAT'S NOW JUST PART OF
CLINTON CLINTON ON HER OWN,
33,000 EMAILS FROM HER
SHE ACID WATCHED THEM.
SHE USED BLEACH BIT AND HER
AIDES WERE SMASHING MOBILE
DEVICES HAMMERS.
IT DIDN'T HAVE A SIM CARD.
HUSBAND WHO DOESN'T EMAIL.
AND IT WAS ABOUT A WEDDING,
A FUNERAL AND YOGA AND GRAND
KIDS.
HERE IS ANOTHER WRINKLE TO
THIS SCANDAL THAT IS
DISTURBING THAT NEEDS TO BE
INVESTIGATED.
ACCORDING TO DOCUMENTS THAT
JUDICIAL WATCH RECEIVED
CLINTON'S CALLS, SCHEDULES
WERE BLOCKED FROM BEING MADE
PUBLIC AND WERE ALLOWED TO
BE REMOVED.
THAT'S INTERESTING WHEN YOU
CONSIDER THIS ARTICLE FROM
THE A.P. IN AUGUST OF 2016.
THE HEADLINE MANY DONORS TO
CLINTON FOUNDATION MET WITH
HER AT STATE.
AND THE ARTICLE GOES ON TO
DETAIL, QUOTE:  AT LEAST 85
OF 154 PEOPLE FROM PRIVATE
INTEREST WHO MET OR WHO HAD
PHONE CONVERSATIONS
SCHEDULED WITH CLINTON WHILE
SHE LED THE STATE
PLEDGED COMMITMENTS TO ITS
INTERNATIONAL PROGRAMS.
NOW, AND ACCORDING TO A
REVIEW OF STATE DEPARTMENT
CALENDARS RELEASED SO FAR TO
AS $156 MILLION.
GAVE MORE THAN A MILLION.
SO IS THAT WHY CLINTON AND
ABEDIN WANTED TO REMOVE
THIS WOULD HAVE COME OUT IN
THE CAMPAIGN?
AND PEOPLE WOULD HAVE BEEN
ASKING GOOD QUESTIONS?
HERE IN JUST A FEW MINUTES.
ALSO TONIGHT BREAKING,
INVESTIGATIVE REPORTER SARAH
CARTER IS OUT WITH DAMNING
NEW DETAILS ON THIS
MAY HAVE BEEN USED TO
COLLECT INFORMATION ON
AMERICANS WITHOUT A WARRANT.
THESE PEOPLE NOT HEAR OF A
U.S. CONSTITUTION AGAINST
UNREASONABLE SEARCH AND
SEIZURE?
THAT WOULD BE NUMBER 4.
SARAH CARTER REPORTING THAT
NUMEROUS FORMER INTELLIGENCE
ON THIS POTENTIALLY
DANGEROUS CONDUCT IN THE WAY
YOUR GOVERNMENT IS
CONDUCTING SURVEILLANCE.
AND THIS IS GETTING SCARY.
ACCORDING TO THE REPORT,
WELL, THE OFFICIALS WERE
CONCERNED OVER A PRACTICE
THAT IS KNOWN AS REVERSE
TARGETING, WHICH, QUOTE,
OCCURS WHEN INTELLIGENCE AND
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICIALS
USE A FOREIGN PERSON AS A
LEGAL PRETENSE FOR THEIR
INTENDED TARGET.
AN AMERICAN CITIZEN.
IN OTHER WORDS, WITHOUT A
WARRANT.
IN OTHER WORDS, ILLEGAL.
IN OTHER WORDS, NO
CONSTITUTION.
NO FOURTH AMENDMENT.
NOW, SARAH CARTER WILL ALSO
JOIN US IN A MOMENT TO
EXPLAIN HOW THIS PRACTICE
MAY HAVE BEEN USED AS A
POLITICAL WEAPON.
HOW OFTEN HAVE YOU HEARD ME
TALK ABOUT WEAPONIZING OUR
INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY.
WEAPONIZING THE SYSTEM OF
JUSTICE WE HAVE IN THIS
COUNTRY.
DUAL SYSTEM OF JUSTICE.
NOW, ALSO TONIGHT, WE HAVE
BREAKING INFORMATION ABOUT
HOW THE ANTI-TRUMP,
PRO-CLINTON TEXT MESSAGES
FROM THAT FBI AGENT PETER
STRZOK AND HIS FBI LAWYER
GIRLFRIEND LISA PAGE WERE
DISCOVERED.
DOJ INSPECTOR GENERAL
REQUESTED THOSE TEXT
SEVERAL FBI EMPLOYEES THAT
THERE ARE MORE THAN 10,000
OF THEM, TEXT MESSAGES
BETWEEN STRZOK AND HIS GIRL
FRIENDS PAGE.
AS OF NOW, 375, THAT'S IT,
FOX NEWS WAS ABLE TO OBTAIN,
JUST THOSE SHOW A SEVERE
ANTI-TRUMP/PRO-HILLARY
CLINTON BIAS.
THESE TEXT MESSAGES INCLUDE
CALLING TRUMP A LOATHE SOME
HUMAN BEING, AN IDIOT.
THAT IS JUST THE START OF IT
HERE IS WHAT IS RAISING ALL
IN AUGUST OF 2016 STRZOK
TEXTED I WANT TO BELIEVE THE
PATH YOU THREW OUT FOR
CONSIDERATION IN ANDY'S
OFFICE, THAT THERE IS NO WAY
HE GETS ELECTED BUT I'M
AFRAID WE CAN'T TAKE THAT
YOU DIE BEFORE YOU ARE 40.
FOX NEWS BELIEVES WE HAVEN'T
CONFIRM YESTERDAY THAT ANDY
IN THAT MESSAGE IS ANDREW
MCCABE.
THAT WOULD BE THE DEPUTY FBI
DIRECTOR.
THAT'S THE SAME GUY WHOSE
WIFE JILL GOT $700,000 IN
DONATIONS FROM DEMOCRATS,
INCLUDING TERRY MCAULIFF UP
WE ALSO HAVE THIS EXCHANGE.
WE EDITED OUT THE MIDDLE OF
IT WHICH INCLUDE WEB LINK
AND PAGE SAYS MAYBE YOU ARE
MEANT TO STAY WHERE YOU ARE
BECAUSE YOU'RE MEANT TO
PROTECT THE COUNTRY FROM
THAT MENACE.
ISN'T THAT GREAT TO TAKE
THAT ALL UPON THEMSELVES?
STRZOK REPLIES YES.
ABSOLUTELY TRUE THAT WE'RE
BOTH VERY FORTUNATE AND, OF
COURSE, I WILL TRY AND
APPROACH IT THAT WAY.
I JUST KNOW IT WILL BE TOUGH
AT TIMES.
I CAN PROTECT OUR COUNTRY AT
MANY LEVELS, NOT SURE IF
THAT HELPS.
NOW, WHY WOULD STRZOK, WHY
WOULD HIS GIRLFRIEND PAGE
AND WHO WE NOW THINK IS
DONALD TRUMP IF HE IS ON HIS
WAY TO WIN THE ELECTION?
WHAT EXACTLY DID THAT MEAN?
NOW, JUDICIAL WATCH JUST
ANNOUNCED IT HAS FILED A
LAWSUIT TO GAIN ACCESS TO
ALL FBI RECORDS ABOUT THE
REMOVAL OF STRZOK FROM THE
MUELLER INVESTIGATION.
HERE'S WHAT THE DEAL IS.
YOU, THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
YOU DESERVE ANSWERS.
THERE'S A LOT AT STAKE HERE.
THERE IS ALL WREAKS OF THIS
DEEP STATE WE HAVE BEEN
TELLING YOU ABOUT, AND THEIR
PRESIDENT.
AND THE "WALL STREET
JOURNAL" IS REPORTING THAT
THIS APPARENT MEETING
SAME TIME THE FBI STARTED
COUNTER INTELLIGENCE
INVESTIGATION INTO, QUOTE:
POSSIBLE TRUMP/RUSSIA TIES.
AND AS WE HAVE BEEN TELLING
YOU THIS FBI AGENT PETER
STRZOK IS TIED TO
EVERYTHING.
AND FBI LAWYER GIRLFRIEND
ALSO SERVED ON ROBERT
MUELLER'S TEAM.
HERE'S WHAT WE KNOW ABOUT
STRZOK.
BEFORE BEING DENOTED
BEFORE BEING DEEOTED
BEFORE BEING DEE DED
BEFORE BEING DEE DEE MOATED
FROM MUELLER'S INVESTIGATION
HE WAS A TOP OFFICIAL.
HE WALLS THE GUY THAT
ACTUALLY SIGNED THE DOCUMENT
THAT KICKED OFF THE RUSSIAN
THE ANTI-TRUMP DOSSIER, THE
RUSSIAN PROPAGANDA WHEN IT
WAS GIVEN TO THE FBI.
HE WAS IN CHARGE OF THE
INTERVIEW OF FORMER NATIONAL
SECURITY ADVISOR LIEUTENANT
GENERAL MICHAEL FLYNN.
GIVING STRZOK
ANTI-TRUMP/PRO-MILLER TEXT
MESSAGES HE ALSO PLAYED A
PIVOTAL ROLE IN THIS CLINTON
EMAIL EXONERATION SO-CALLED
INVESTIGATION.
THIS INCLUDES SITTING IN ON
HILLARY'S FBI INTERVIEW.
WRITING THE EXONERATION.
HE WAS ALSO IN THE ROOM FOR
THE INTERVIEWS WITH KLEE
CLINTON AIDES HUMA ABEDIN
AND CHERYL MILLS.
THIS IS THE MOST DAMAGING
INFORMATION WHEN IT COMES TO
STRZOK.
HE IS THE GUY, HE IS THE ONE
THAT ACTUALLY CHANGED THE
LEGAL STANDARD LANGUAGE IN
JAMES COMEY'S EXONERATION
STATEMENT FROM GROSSLY
NEGLIGENT TO EXTREME CARE
ALSONESS.
THAT ALLOWED HILLARY CLINTON
IN FROM THE GET-GO.
EVEN THOUGH WE KNOW SHE
BROKE THE LAW.
WHAT IN GOD'S NAME IS ROBERT
MUELLER THINKING?
CORRUPT FBI AGENT AND SO
INVESTIGATIVE TEAM:  MUELLER
CLAIMS TO HAVE IMPECCABLE
INTEGRITY.
A STERLING REPUTATION.
WHY WOULD ANYBODY ALLOW THAT
TO HAPPEN?
CONSIDER ALL THE DEMOCRATIC
DONORS THAT MUELLER HAS HAND
PICKED TO BE PART OF THE
INVESTIGATION.
NOW, THESE INVESTIGATORS
BARACK OBAMA AND, YOU
GUESSED IT, HILLARY CLINTON.
JUST ONE DONATED TO A
REPUBLICAN AND NONE OF THEM
GAVE ANY MONEY TO THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN.
THIS ENTIRE INVESTIGATION IS
CORRUPT TO ITS CORE.
IT HAS NOW BECOME A
SESSIONS DO MISS JOB.
IT'S TIME FOR YOU THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE TO
UNDERSTAND.
THIS ACCORDING TO A NEW
POLL, 54% SAY ROBERT MUELLER
HAS A CONFLICT OF INTEREST.
BECAUSE OF HIS FRIENDSHIP,
THESE BFF WITH JAMES COMEY.
FRIENDS, AND AS FOX NEWS
LEGAL ANALYST GREGG JARRETT
HAS POINTED OUT ON MANY AN
OCCASION, THEIR RELATIONSHIP
COULD ACTUALLY BE A
VIOLATION OF THE LAW.